vous êtes noir vous êtes juif vous êtes
homosexuel et vous êtes séropositif
[Musique]
Mickey
vous êtes le rappeur qui brise les
tabous dans le monde du hip-hop vous
êtes noir vous êtes juif vous êtes
homosexuel et vous êtes séropositif
après des années à enchaîner les
festivals à travers le monde et à
collaborer avec des gens aussi
prestigieux que Bjork ou base vous
sortez votre premier album qui est
produit par Woodkid césarien on
regardera le clip tout à l'heure vous
êtes né le 2 avril
1986 dans le comté d'Orange en
Californie sous le nom de Michael Davy
catalbum junior
parce que votre père s'appelait pareil
donc il vous a dit junior
parce que tu es amoureux
c'est quand même il faut que j'en bosse
un peu merde alors votre père
afro-américain de confession juive
informaticien chez Siemens et puis un
jour il devient médium
branles alors votre mère avocate en
propriété intellectuelle et vous avez
deux ans quand vos parents se séparent
vous aviez deux ans c'est pas un
traumatisme
je ne connaissais pas les opinions
politiques de Henri
pour ceux qui m'a semblé très
intéressant dans son intervention
des lesbiennes
je pense que je préfère avoir deux
parents homosexuels qui sont fidèles que
des hétérosexuels qui commettent un
adultère par exemple
mes parents avaient des différences qui
n'étaient pas réconciliables
c'est
tellement bête pardonnez-moi de traiter
de fasciste sous les gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec vous vous savez ce que
c'est que le fascisme vous avez déjà
regardé l'histoire de l'Europe les camps
de concentration les camps de la mort
vous savez ce que c'est que le fascisme
[Musique]
évidemment à l'école vous êtes harcelé
par les autres élèves qui vous traitent
de [__]
comme ça tu traduis bien alors mais
malgré ça vous êtes plein d'ambition et
vous voulez devenir yokono vous êtes le
seul mec que je connaisse qui veut
devenir yokono parce que nous on voulait
devenir les Beatles on détestait au
Congo qu'elle était la cause de la
séparation des Beatles mais vous vous
voulez être iokono
pas en raison de son impact sur la
culture pop plutôt son travail en tant
que à travailler dans l'installation
artistique tout à fait du mouvement
Fluxus
lorsque j'étais plus jeune ce sont des
idées qui étaient très radicales
absolument Jean bon
à l'époque votre rêve c'est de conquérir
New York et à l'âge de 16 ans Miki vous
piquez 100 dollars dans le portefeuille
de votre maman et vous arrivez à New
York
[Musique]
à New York comme vous n'avez pas
d'argent pour dormir vous restez éveillé
toute la nuit c'est pas con il sait pas
où dormir qu'est-ce qu'il fait il se
couche pas bon
et là en fait le seul moment où vous
dormez c'est quand vous squattez chez
les amants que vous rencontrez dans les
bars
aussi
ça peut aider à se cultiver et là donc
il y a un bar que vous aimez beaucoup
qui s'appelle coq c'est à dire la queue
et là vous commencez à faire un peu le
gogo boy pour 50 dollars vous dansez nu
sur le comptoir Miki
alors là vous fréquentez le milieu de
l'art new-yorkais et en 2010 pour une
vidéo vous inventez le personnage de
Miki Blanco vous publiez un recueil de
poésie
qui s'appelle du silence de Duchamp
en sorte que les gens s'impliquent dans
la poésie
ce qu'il fallait c'est prendre ses
poèmes et en faire des paroles et là
vous découvrez que vous avez un vrai
talent pour le phraser râpé la rappeuse
Miki Blanco est né et c'est vrai que
dans le milieu du rap qui est un milieu
de mec de bourrin on peut dire lui c'est
la seule rappeuse du rap voilà c'est
Miki Blanco il est là ce soir vous
devenez l'icône de la communauté
LGBT de New York et vous faites des
tournées en Europe et aux USA bien
évidemment mais
en mars 2015 c'est le drame
[Musique]
vous révéler Micky le secret que vous
gardez depuis 5 ans vous êtes
séropositif et le fait de le dire vous
permet d'échapper à votre prison mentale
ce que je souhaitais c'était réussir
mais il y avait une face cachée
quelqu'un que j'aimais bien par exemple
et lorsque nous avions une relation
intime
immédiatement j'étais obligé de dire
est-ce que vous voulez est-ce que tu
veux bien garder un secret pour moi
et ce n'est pas possible de vivre ainsi
et alors contre toute attente la
révélation de votre séropositivité
provoque une réaction bienveillante ce
qu'on peut dire Miki
c'est finalement ce coming out HIV a été
quand même finalement une bénédiction
cela aurait été une condamnation à mort
comprendre les réalités des choses
il faut sensibiliser les gens plus les
gens sont instruits les gens sont
éduqués
moins ils ont de préjugés
sera possible d'informer des gens et de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait de la
prévention nécessaire merci
Mick merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu